على الصعيد الميدانيه قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان قواتها قصفت خلال الساعات
الماضيه اكثر من 10 مناطق لتمركز القوات
الروسيه داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه واضافت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه في المقابل نفذت امس سبعه غارات
جويه واكثر من 70 رشقه صاروخيه مستهدفه
بشكل اساسي البنيه التحتيه المدنيه في
مقاطعات اوكرانيه عده مشيره الى سقوط قتلى
ومصابين في صفوف المدنيين
وفي مقاطعه خيرسون جنوبا افاده مراسل
الجزيره بسماع دوي انفجارات ضخمه وقال ان
قصف المكثفا يتواصل بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه على ضفتي نهر دنبر ونقل مراسلنا
عن السلطات الاوكرانيه قولها ان الروس
قصفوا الضفه اليمنى من المقطعه اكثر من
100 مره خلال اليوم الماضي مستخدمين
المدفعيه الثقيله وقاذفات الهاون
في الاسماء اعلن احاكم ومقاطعه ذكروازياء
الكسندر ستروخ ان القوات الروسيه كشفت
قصفها للمقطعه خلال الساعات الاربع
والعشرين الماضيه واضاف الصاروخ ان القصف
الروسي الدالي تدمير 64 مبنا سكنيا ومنشات
للبنيه التحتيه المدنيه وقالت السلطات
الاوكرانيه في المقاطعه ان الروس يرسلون
مزيدا من التعزيزات باتجاه مواقع الجنوبي